I don't think there's a better example
of how humanity changed the landscape of
New Zealand than right here at this
dividing line between wild forests and
managed farmland it's a little bit
difficult to see close up though for the
best of you you need to go a few
kilometers that way in the center of
that circle is Mount Taranaki a
stratovolcano on the west coast of New
Zealand's North Island and from six
kilometers up the landscape looks
bizarre there are very few large-scale
circular features like that in the world
Taranaki is also one of the most
symmetrical volcanoes on the planet
which adds to the effect that mountain
is one of the natural features of New
Zealand it's been granted the legal
rights of a person in sort of the same
way that corporations are considered
people in a lot of countries although
the nuances of math and the history of
war and land confiscation that got us to
this point is something that this
British tourist is entirely unqualified
to talk about so I'll put some links at
the end of the video in the description
before humans arrived in New Zealand
about seven hundred years ago most of
the country look something like this
dense forest not that exact species of
tree everywhere but certainly that's
sort of haven for wildlife and birds
Marra settlers cleared some of it after
they landed here but the European
settlers a few centuries later they
cleared forests on an industrial scale
trees that were valuable for
construction were cut down and anything
else was burned making way for this sort
of pastureland about half of New Zealand
was eventually converted to grasslands
for grazing for imported species of
animals on imported species of grass the
national government reserved an area
around that peak to help defend against
flash floods and erosion and in 1900
that area became a national park defined
as a circle six miles in radius from the
summit of the mountain plus a few other
interesting parts on the edge farmers of
course cleared everything up to that
circle as far as they could legally go
and the result was this mathematical
line made real this wonderful view out
the window as he fly from Auckland to
Wellington although at some point that
flight is going to become a bit more
difficult as is living around here
because Taranaki is not an extinct
volcano under that rock they're still
magma ready to go
Taranaki is active just quiet right now
and it's overdue on average there's at
least a minor eruption every 90 years
and it's been more than 150 since the
last one one study said there's an 80%
chance of some sort
eruption in the next 50 years there will
be warning signs and plenty of time to
evacuate folks but if it's the big one
the government civil defense evacuation
plans describe the entire National Park
as an area where people are unlikely to
survive and it could shut down air
traffic of most of the North Island
engine shredding ash will probably blow
East right into that flight path and the
count the mountain could collapse
entirely as it's done several times in
the eons when humans weren't around to
see it
so if you are flying between Auckland
and Wellington any time soon and the
skies are clear do enjoy the view
because at some point it's gonna change
you